oh my god it's not even moving we are
joined by a very special guest he is a
big-time director so I have to ask what
is your technique for having people act
against imaginary things I get you
expressvpn for sponsoring today's
episode stay tuned to the end to learn
how you can get your first three months
free hey what's up everyone welcome back
to another episode of visual effects
artists react today we are joined by a
very special guest David F Sandberg
hello
also known as pony smasher that's right
he is a big-time director he's done
three Hollywood films on top of being a
director you're also a visual effects
are it's kind of yeah yeah I mean Shazam
there's not a lot of finals but for
everything I've done a lot of temp works
well I think we'll be taking a look at
some of those today I am a big fan of
like smoke simulations and those are
some really cool smoke simulations the
thing was that they were actually
supposed to always have a bit of steam
or smoke and I actually found this
reference of like a warm horse on a
winter cold winter day that was sort of
steaming the whole time but then as you
get closer and closer to deadlines is
just like smoke simulations take forever
to calculate yeah if you kind of like to
choose your battles it was really hard
actually getting that look right because
I didn't want it to seem like it's
geometry that just smoke comes out of
when they turn into smoke like I wanted
to feel that no they actually turn into
smoke
the boardroom scene was actually a
reshoot they had to really hurry to get
that done in time and and it was that
thing I'm like okay we have to shoot
that first give it to the VFX house so
they can start working on it right away
and you don't have time for a lot of
revisions you in that shot greed in the
back there his animation is not great
he's just sort of kind of like saying
he's just doing this thing but it was
just like we don't really have to
because again you know animation takes
forever because first you have to lock
down the main animation and then you
have to do all the secondaries the
flabby skin or the muscles or the drool
in their mouths and everything visual
effects to you who's never intend to
make like bad effects it's usually
running out of time exactly I have to
ask what is your technique for having
people act against imaginary things well
here we had stunt guys in like where a
kind of motion capture suits but we
didn't actually capture the motions they
were just there for something to look at
so you basically shoot things three
times you know you shoot it once with an
actor and then like a stunt double in a
suit and then you shoot it with just the
actor reacting to nothing and then you
shoot a clean play what the visual
effects folks would prefer is to add the
monsters into the plate with just the
actors right reacting to nothing but
their reactions won't look as good as
the shots where you have a stunt guy
exactly you've made a video kind of
talking about this scene on your own
YouTube channel it's a fantastic video I
highly recommend you check it out but
there's one thing in particular that
blew me away you actually had your crew
in the scene unintentionally yeah and
you had to fix that in post well because
we realized as so late that they were
still in the shot and we'd forgotten to
paint them out we came up with this idea
of like well let's paint in Lowell
shopping bags in their hands and like
one of them they're you know it has a
little mop bucket you can see a little
later they still don't really react to a
man flying and super shopping-mall
certain things you just get blind to
because of course we're looking at him
is he looking all right that's eye
shadow come flying if I really
look closely it looks like it's a 3d
double there right oh yeah him him
sivanna flying and sac I mean his entire
body is CG when he's you know trying to
jump they've matched moved really his
actual movement because we had him in a
big rig that's kind of like a seesaw
uh-huh right even if you paint the rig's
out you can still tell like okay this is
where he was attached and you can like
it you don't get that fluid movement so
you have to often just recreate the
motion and do a CG double interesting
okay so it's sometimes it's like well
maybe we should have just not shot it
with him and just done it all CGI but at
the same time you do get a lot of
reference for lighting or everything so
yeah you know exactly what it should
look like because you filmed it for real
even if it's not being used yeah I think
they were able to actually take his real
head and put it on there because the CG
head didn't look quite right
okay funny how you can have a CG body
and it doesn't look fake but just the
head like just the head stands out so
this scene here you know I just take a
look at it I look at your thoughts
[Music]
mmm-hmm looks like it floats around a
bit I'm still frame this looks
completely real yeah I've been in that
situation many times where you're in a
visual effects review and it's like this
doesn't look real but I don't know what
notes to give because it's like that
shadow looks right that looks right but
but as a whole
something just screams fake about it if
I were to try to figure out what it is
that makes a shot look fake well for one
it's the rocks head is filmed separately
from the body so he's trying to mimic a
movement in that you know the compositor
is trying to animate a doll to fit but
they're not actually all moving the same
way in motion is one of those things
that like everybody's so finely tuned
for it's hard to always express what
looks weird but like we can always feel
it if the motion is that weird because
we're also familiar with physics and
gravity and how things should move in
inertia but the other one is that the
lighting on his head the angle of the
lighting on his head doesn't actually
match the angle of the lighting in the
world on the left there that backpack
strap is pretty much getting direct
light hitting Andy from the front left a
little bit but his face is in shadow on
the front left and then the collar isn't
putting any shadow on his neck and
that's how always one of those
challenging things of like a CG costume
or something fake like touching
somebody's in that contact shadow and
everything if you aren't already please
consider subscribing because that will
help you actually see whenever these
videos come out when they come out so
that you can be the first to tell your
friends about what's in these episode so
speaking of heads there's this character
in a TV show called Watchmen a show that
I adore by the way it's amazing there's
a character named mirror guy technically
his name is looking leer guy that's my
secret okay he has this mask on that's
very reflective and the effects here are
kind of invisible but also super
in-your-face looking glasses head that
mask 100% computer-generated but what
makes it work so well are the
reflections the one shot out of this
entire show that blew me away the most
is when he takes out that yellow rag any
wipes his head that's a perfect
reflection but it's the proximity of
that reflection yeah it's like you
actually got like that surface contact
when you put your hand up against a
mirror you can actually see the
underside of your hand against the
mirror and you kind of get that same
effect here mmm
yeah that's crazy first off they get a
360 image for the reflection of
everywhere but that's not everything
they also actually reproject all of that
information on to 3d
geometry because the problem with a 360
image is that everything is the same
distance from the center of that sphere
and if you're trying to do interactive
reflections where you know he's actually
moving through space the reflection of a
desk in the background is gonna be the
same size as someone standing next to
the camera at least in terms of depth so
they had to project the images onto that
to get proper like parallax of the
reflections in addition to that they
actually put a GoPro on his face really
for all of like the actual high detail
close-up reflects what's actually in
there yeah exactly
there's so much work you were almost
like what would have been better if you
just paint out the cameras but I think a
part of it is that you can't
well that rate a map initially when they
planned this show they wanted to
actually have it for real and do it
practically and just paint out the
camera except for the fact that they
couldn't get a material that could do
both be stretchy enough to fit over his
head and also be reflective enough to be
that near like effect that they were
going for sorry
okay being a director of course I'm just
thinking like oh I wonder if they had to
cut scenes with looking glass because it
was his studio was like oh this is too
expensive less scenes with him who knows
maybe he was the star of the show
nope they did a lot of cloth animations
and simulations to get that mask to fit
to his head but again they also had an
actual mask form fitted around his head
so they knew exactly how to make it look
so usually we ask for comments for
scenes or shows or movies that we should
react to but I'm gonna ask for something
different this time if there's a guest
that you think we should get on the show
please leave that in account block
because they've obviously run out of
ideas
don't say captain disillusion we know
we're trying we'd love to have him on
what would you say is probably like the
best the effect shot you've done on a
feature movie I like the the end credits
of Annabelle creation did that in
blender just scanned in a whole bunch of
Bible pages and then sort of model them
so they looked right and did the camera
mode you just did that in your bedroom
at home in blender yeah that's wonder
right there this is real like a real
photo that's projected and then as soon
as the camera sort of turns here now
this is all CGI
it was a long secret to took a while to
render on my laptop you did feature
visual effects on a laptop how did you
learn blender what got you into it how
did you train yourself blender guru and
you know YouTube I mean that's where you
can learn all the software and all these
guys making great stuff it's really
inspiring all right so they're app
things up here gonna look at one more
clip it's uh those jaws there is jaws -
and there's jaws 3d so yeah let's take a
look at that let's see let's react to
that oh my god you're supposed to be
like scared but I just can't help me be
pulled out of it doesn't look like the
Sharks there at all
also just stops as soon as he hits the
glass he just becomes motionless it's
almost like you freeze-frame look yeah I
mean look the comps yeah that black
outline you're talking about is from the
track Matt's not perfectly aligning
right yeah in our Star Wars VFX artists
react we talked about this some more and
if you want to give an idea of how
visual effects are done back in the day
before computers definitely go check out
that video
[Music]
let's go that's cool okay I dig it yeah
okay and now there's a rod with the jaws
way too literal
just like hey I've got squid like squid
got a gift like a
quake3 character look at the guts look
at your lower intestines wait a minute
is that a liquid simulation I mean a
really almost looks like they paint it
like it's animated or something like it
hand animated or almost it looks very
strange because it almost has a drop
shadow but it's got like that classic
low resolution liquid simulation look to
where it's all just kind of like
globules there's no way in 1983 there's
no way so you're suggesting that they
painted it I don't know it's almost too
smooth but I mean yeah it's almost like
it's just 2d animation right those
eyeballs oh yeah this is two giant
eyeball spider shark yeah the size don't
match though because the eyes are much
bigger than the jaws there and the fact
that the eyes are in the foreground but
composited behind the jaws in the
background and it's none of the frame
rates match it's okay this movie's
almost 40 years old also shark skeletons
are made out of cartilage not bone so
that's just another movie learned
something today
hey guys Brandi O'Daniel here and I
heard that on this very show back in
November Sam and the boys did a little
expressvpn sponsorship segment that I
thought would be fun to go through right
now and just see what happens when when
I'm not in the brand segment so let's
hop into it hi my name is Sam Gorski
cofounder of corridor digital I'm here
today to tell you about a work from one
of our sponsors expressvpn that's pretty
good that's really nice and smooth intro
it's well lit and he kind of does a
little point which makes me feel special
and lets me know that this video is
sponsored by expressvpn the VPN is for
privacy
it basically encrypts and helps keep
your data safe this is good Sam
immediately starts with what they call
the talking points you know he starts
talking about what a VPN does how it
gives you extra security and how it
gives you extra privacy when you're on
the internet so that your information
isn't just out there to the open
Internet the first time I use it I
totally noticed you
this privacy the security even the
content unblocking whether you're a
chrome guy a Firefox gal or a safari
whatever the expressvpn has an extension
for every single one and now I know that
expressvpn can pretty much be found on
any platform on any device listen seven
dollars a month with a 30-day money-back
guarantee this is my favorite part right
here watch what Sam does this little bit
Li RI d o RC r e W and you can go do eet
x PR e SS V P and calm look at that look
at that and then Ren comes in with a
double tap because you never really hear
information until you hear at 2 or 3
times so if you guys go to expr ESS BPM
comm slash corridor crew you'll get
three months free just by signing up
with the link in the description below
wow that was really good I better be
careful he might almost put me out of a
job here I mean town next time Brandi Oh
Daniel catch you on the flipside well
thank you so much for watching and David
thank you so much for joining us it's an
absolute pleasure really
come on are having somebody that has
such a body of work that you have but
also a willingness to share that
information come out here and talk to us
and she won't break the process of
creating this this art form and that's
super super cool I hope you keep it up I
will thank you yeah and best of luck
with your future projects thank you
you're working on Shazam - now right
like pre-production and writing yes so
that's coming out in April of 22 oh dang
uh still two years away
I know it's whoa I know what I'm doing
for the next two years we'll be seeing
you in 2022 April yes and I'll be very
tired
[Laughter]